so hello everyone a very warm greeting
to one and all my name is shrii and I
would like to welcome you all for the
webinar on omix logic multiomic research
program so this program is a
comprehensive research uh program that
covers various aspects of omix data
analysis and research and it's designed
to accommodate a wide range of
participants from high school students
to experience researchers and the
program offers a Hands-On approach to B
informatics guiding you from basic data
analysis to Advanced research
methodologies with even opportunities
for publication and now in this webinar
we will be covering several topics such
as key features and Associated resources
of the research program introduction to
our Cloud research infrastructure help
you choose the right specialization
track that best aligns with your career
goals an interactive life to session as
well as the various scholarship
opportunities that are available to the
participant and uh before we begin with
today's webinar let me also take a brief
moment to introduce you to the team
behind the program since I can see that
couple of participants are new to us and
uh are hearing about the program for the
very first time so we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and Commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make B informatics more accessible well
and now we have had the opportunity to
work with coordinators from different
parts of the world to offer btic
training programs reaching 24K plus
participants in different countries
across different specializations
including oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine neuroscience and data
science and as a part of the program you
will have access to the omix L resources
which includes training modules data
analysis tools curated project data sets
and interactive sessions with the
mentors to give the student a clear path
of the Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and now
this also comes with an access to our
course fors which include courses on BI
informatics Precision medicine
multiomics including genomics transomics
metagenomics and EP genomics data
science that includes btics using R and
Python Programming as well as CH
informatic and examp projects of
different fields which you could learn
from and replicate for your research
work now the OM logic platform also
gives options for analyzing a given data
for instance you can learn B informatics
without any coding at all and for those
interested in opting the non code
pathway they will be given directions to
access the T by info platform for
bomatic processing and Analysis of data
and this platform includes demo pipeline
as well as data management and Analysis
Cloud infrastructure to run the pipeline
so now to view the various courses
example projects and student projects
we'll first start by signing up on the
omix project learn portal and I'll walk
you do a brief demo on how you can get
started so here is the link for signing
up okay so here for those of you who are
new to this uh program and you're
hearing about it for the very first time
then uh this is the learn platform where
the participants once they enroll in the
program they'll be able to access
various training resources that they get
access to so to be able to guide you on
how you can uh get started you need to
first sign account to be able to do that
if you don't have an account uh
previously on the portal you can visit
the link that I've shared in the chat
box and click on the create an account
option that you see
here and once you click on this you will
be asked to enter your name email ID and
password as well as several few details
such as your University uh and so so you
can enter those details and click on
submit and your profile will be great or
if you already have an existing social
uh account such as Google Facebook Apple
GitHub or Twitter you can simply
directly click on those and create an
account linked with your existing social
media handle so with that I'll just
pause for a couple of seconds for the
participants to sign up so that I can
help you walk walk you through the
different uh components on the portal
where the mentor will be guiding you as
a part of the research program in just a
while so let me know in the chat once
you have signed up please put a yeah and
if you already have a existing account
on the portal and you are good to go put
a done in the
chat and uh I have opened my chat box in
on the side so I'll just uh pause for
two to three minutes so that you can
find okay Shia has already signed up
risi has also signed
up if you're facing any technical issues
while you're are trying to login or
creating an account you can uh let us
know in the chat box and our technical
team will be able to uh help resolve the
issue so that you can
ask
well done aash she has also signed
up thank you
Nika all right kavia has also signed
up Sak has also signed
up
all right lxmi has also signed up so
I'll just uh proceed ahead with
navigating and show uh showing you how
you can get started started uh so please
feel free to continue to let me know in
the chat once you have signed up and if
you have any issues once again uh you
can let us know so I'm going to sign in
using my existing uh social media uh
existing email ID and
password so here once you sign up uh you
will be able to see the very first page
that you are seeing is the courses page
right so before we uh navigate to that
the first thing that you have to do once
you sign up is to complete your profile
so to be able to do that on the top blue
bar you will see welcome back with your
email ID click on that and it will take
you to your account right and here you
will see a profile button click on that
and here the first thing that you have
to do is complete your
profile right incl uh make sure that
your name is in proper capitalization
and there is no spelling error because
as you complete the courses and you get
the certificate
this name will be printed on it and also
add a brief bu about yourself as your
educational background and research
interest and link to your social media
profile and add a uh profile picture or
uh your University's logo and your
profile should be showing 100% complete
right and now you if you head to the
courses tab that you see here you'll be
able to see the various courses that we
uh provide on the portal uh which ranges
topics from introduction to
bioinformatics genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics as well as case
studies on various uh specialization
topics such as oncology infectious
diseases and so so here in the search
bar if you enter a keyword that you are
interested to learn more about let's say
you are interested to learn genomics
then you can simply enter that and
display the relevant forces and example
prods and now another tab that I want to
show show you is the programs tab there
you will find the research program um
that is part of today's webinar right
and along with that you'll also see
several other training programs in
different fields that you can explore at
uh your own pH so uh that is all that I
wanted to talk about in uh getting
started on the omix logic learn portal
and navigating on the portal and now to
introduce you to the training program
the various features the associ
resources and various specialization
tracks I would like to pass on the stage
to my colleague sikar who is also
mentors of the program over to
you thank you so much Shari for the
overview and a very warm welcome to all
of you uh good morning good evening or
afternoon in whichever part of the world
you are I'm sonalika R and I'm the
bioinformatics project manager manager
at P biotech and today we are going to
talk about the structure of our research
fellowship program we have designed this
program to cater to Learners from all
the backgrounds and we have organized it
into three distinct levels to ensure a
gradual and in an in-depth Learning
Journey so the question that arises is
why you should join the omx logic
community and the training and the
research program now what is the need so
to answer this question in the ever
evolving field of omix research there's
continous advancements in technology and
software that has improved processing
capabilities but the data sets under
study are often vast and they require
substantial Computing part and memory as
well beyond what most personal computers
SC handle and accessing and working with
publicly a uh available data data can be
complex typically requiring coding
skills which many biologists lack
likewise the analysis pipelines and the
programs that are involved often demand
coding expertise and in University
settings the students receive valuable
theoretical knowledge in research
project design but they lack the
knowledge in research project design or
a hands-on experience due to these
technical
limitations
and the faculty members often specialist
in their own research areas May struggle
to cover diverse topics or unfamiliar
Technologies outside their expertise for
instance a professor well vered in
oncogene expression we have limited
knowledge of metagenomics and sea water
so to address these several issues that
are present in terms of what is there in
uh the Academia and uh how you can work
on the research process without being an
expert with the coding we'll try to
understand today how we can join the
program and learn from this program how
we can use the automated pipelines to
process or automate our research work
and get our results to interpret
insights spend less time on uh working
with the code block for analysis but
more time on the
interpretation so the omix logic
research program is designed to Prov
provide an exceptional opportunity for
researchers and students to delve into
the world of bioinformatics and harness
its potential for analyzing complex life
science data and through a well
structured blend of online resources and
personalized guidance from expert
mentors the students would engage in
diverse omix research
projects now who can join the program so
omix logic is an all encompassing
platform designed to meet the needs of a
wide range of knowledge Seekers it is
inclusive and welcomes everyone
including high school students or
graduates researchers even individuals
from non- bioinformatics backgrounds so
whether you are just starting your
educational Journey have a degree in
hand or you are pursuing Cutting Edge
research omx logic would offer resources
courses and tools that would cater to
your unique level of expertise and
interest and it's a space where
individuals with diverse backgrounds and
goals can come together to explore and
engage with the exciting world of
bioinformatics and omix data
analysis the research fellowship program
is designed with three Progressive
levels that cater to individuals of all
the backgrounds so there are three
levels beginner intermediate and
advanced the beginner level spans around
two months it provides foundational
knowledge with predefined research
questions and project reports the
intermediate level would last for three
months and it will let you propose your
own research question and work on a
desertation finally the advanced level
spans around six months that equips you
with Advanced Data science tools and
techniques to address your research
question aiming for research publication
and this inclusive program would welcome
high school students graduates
researchers and those without a
bioinformatics background ensuring that
anyone can embark on a rewarding
research Journey I'll take you through
each one of these levels in more depth
and we try to understand what are these
different levels all
about before I get on to discussing
about these different levels I wanted to
discuss about the different resource
specialization track track s that you
can work on in the research fellowship
program so there are several tracks that
you can work on one of them is oncology
oncology research focuses on cancer
related studies and therapies then you
have Precision medicine that emphasizes
personalized Health Care based on
individual genetics and characteristics
then you have infectious diseases that
explode diseases caused by pathogens
such as bacteria viruses and fungi then
are metabolic disorders that Encompass
research on conditions like diabetes and
obesity then you have Neuroscience that
investigates the brain and the nervous
system to understand the cognition and
disorders and then there are Fields like
system biology agriculture space omics
and chem informatics system biology
studies complex biological systems and
their interactions as agriculture
research centers on improving crop yield
and sustainability and space omix
examines omix data and space
environments for space exploration a
very interesting field that's coming up
and then you have chem informatics that
focuses on computational methods for
chemical
research we have met a lot of research
fellows and some of them come with an
idea what they want to work on a topic
or a field that they want to work on
with and different types of data that
they want to explore but we also meet a
lot of newbies who are not sure or not
clear which specific path do they want
to select that's why we wanted to
discuss about the different tracks that
you can pick your research question from
and get started now the now there are
different types of research
specialization tracks that I just
discussed and what type of study is
possible under uh the track but I also
wanted to discuss what type of data for
all of these different tracks can you
explore so in your research journey
within the various specialization tracks
that I just discussed you can harness
the power of diverse omx data types
there are Fields
called uh the generalized word is omics
that is collection of something you have
phenomics genomics epigenetics
transcriptomics there are also Fields
like single cell transcriptomics
metagenomics so genomics allows you to
Del into the genetic makeup of organisms
uncovering DNA variations that are
crucial for precision medicine
Agriculture and space exploration when
you have transcriptomics that provide
insights into the gene expression
patterns shading light on the molecular
mechanisms behind the diseases cellular
diversity and responses to stimuli
single cell transcriptomics will take a
more granular approach examining
individual cell behavior that is vital
for understanding complex systems such
as the nervous system or tumor micro
environments and then you have
epigenomics that explores modifications
to DNA that impacts gene activity aiding
research in areas like metabolic
disorders and neuroses lastly
metagenomics that is invaluable for
investigating the microbial communities
whether in the human gut soil ecosystem
or infectious diseases or offering
insights into the interplay between
hosts and their
microbiota now these omic data types
provide powerful tools to explore the
intricacies of your chosen
specialization and uncovered novel
insights now many of you might be
thinking um that you don't have a
background in omx's field if you are
from I heard uh the participants telling
that they are from biochemistry or
biotechnology or microbiology but not
the code
bioinformatics those who are from the
code bioinformatics field they might
have dealt with such type of omix data
but for the wet lab students you need
not worry we'll take you through a
training process we'll teach you uh a
specific type of omics analysis that
you're interested to work on with and
then take you a step ahead with your
research I'll discuss what the process
looks like in my next slides so that was
about the research specialization tracks
that you can work on uh obviously one
track that you need to pick based on
your research interest but those were
the possibilities from where you can
pick your specific research interest and
the different types of data that you can
work with all these different types of
uh data could be used for each and every
specialization track that I previously
mentioned in the previous
slide so I mentioned that we have three
different uh levels the beginner level
the intermediate level and the advanced
level now these levels definitely vary
in terms of duration in terms of uh the
project the research project question in
terms of the outcomes of the program but
also with the program you have a
specific curriculum that we have put
together to teach you while you're
working on your research project because
as you learn only then you can Implement
those things or those Concepts uh for
your research work so the first level is
the beginner level I'll take you through
very briefly about these different
levels it's very important for you to
understand what each level cats so that
you can pick the level that works for
you at the moment so the beginner level
has three uh has uh six specific
sessions that you need to cover in the
initial phase of uh of your research
work the moment you join the program and
then you start working on your uh
research question the first session in
the first session we will discuss about
how to identify the research gaps and
formulate research questions you'll
learn how to conduct a literature review
to build a strong foundation for your
research in the second session that is
the research proposal and research
methodology we'll dive into the process
of creating a research proposal that
outlines your Project's objectives
significance and
methodology understanding the different
research methodologies and how to choose
the most suitable one for your study
will be the key Focus here and then you
have the third session that is data
analysis and the project timeline so
this session will cover the Bas basics
of data analysis techniques we'll also
discuss how to create a project timeline
ensuring a stay organized and me your
research Milestones the fourth session
would be around budget and resources
ethical considerations and project
management this session is very
important for those who are working on a
research work in an institution it could
be PhD Scholars or researchers I won say
this session would be important for
those uh who are in their graduation or
postgraduation but yes go through the
session so that you know what steps to
uh consider in future so in this session
we'll discuss about budgeting resource
allocation and the importance of
financial planning for your research
ethical considerations in research are
critical and we'll explore the ethical
guidelines as well that you need to
follow you'll also learn about effective
project management to keep your research
on track this is one of the very
important things that I feel every
student uh be it a graduate postgraduate
or a researcher should have a scale of
project management because I've seen a
lot of students working on their project
and missing out on their deadlines and
not me not meeting their Milestones on
time and that really messes up with your
project because the last St you just
rush and put together everything uh not
making complete sense of your results
also I've have seen that because you
don't have the project management skills
you work a lot but you're not able to
put together a good meaningful
presentation to showcase the work you
really did um for months so this is what
we'll discuss next the next session is
on data collection and validation and
data interpretation so this session will
focus on collecting and validating data
for your research and we'll discuss
methods for data interpretation and how
to draw meaningful conclusions from your
findings we'll discuss somewhat about
the visualizations we'll also cover
about visualization in detail in the
sessions though but this would be an
overview and finally project
presentation project presentation is a
skill to put together everything that
you worked on for months and months to
put together it uh to put it up together
as a story in those slides and present
what you worked on what methodology you
opted what results you opt ained and
then how do you conclude your
presentation is very important so we'll
discuss how to uh compile your project
that effectively communicates your
findings and we'll also cover the
process of submitting your research
project on the portal so that is what
the bner level uh research fellows will
learn now those who join the
intermediate and the advanced levels
will definitely uh learn about about
these several first six sessions that
I've mentioned and also as I mentioned
those who specifically join the beginner
level program only they would be working
on a predefined research question
because it's just for two months now why
did we put this option of a beginner
level curriculum or a beginner level for
the research fellowship program we have
received a lot of queries from different
universities where students are supposed
to work
on a mini project or they want to have a
research project or they want to get an
experience with a specific type of comic
analysis during their internship and
they have to submit their certificate
for internship or mini project or submit
a mini project to their college uh for
their Academia so there are there could
be a number of reasons and there are
also high schoolers who want to work on
a research project present it in an
exhibition or a science fair and that
helps them get uh away or submit their
application or complete their
application to get to their dream
college so there could be a number of
reasons because time is a limit here you
just have two months that you can work
on that's why we have put together some
predefined research questions for you so
we have these research questions that we
are already working on and also we have
uh the pre analysis of the of these
different components already done and
you would be responsible to carry out a
literature review and work on the
analysis and interpretation a customized
analysis that will tell you that you
have to work on so you get the halfway
done and half work done and then you
have to work on the analysis and the
interpretation now I'll tell you about
some of the predefined research
questions that we are proposing today
for different research specialization
tracks you can pick any one of these
predefined research questions if you're
interested to get a taste of the
different research tracks or different
types of omx analysis for your um
experience or Project work the first one
is oncology it is one of the exciting
areas of research to understand how the
specific genetic mutations can lead to
resistance to cancer s and here we are
looking for ways to develop a targeted
therapy to overcome the resistance
another focus is to identify the unique
molecular signatures and the biomarkers
that are associated with the progression
of breast cancer which can lead to more
personalized treatment approaches for
patients now these are the two topics
for oncology I have just specified two
such questions for each of the tracks
but if you wish to work on a different
uh specific track we can have a call and
we can let you know about the other
topics that we are working on as well
the next is a Precision medicine so
Precision medicine is all about
tailoring treatments to individual
patients and we are researching how to
identify the genetic and the molecular
markers that can predict how a person
would respond to specific medication and
this can lead to highly personalized
treatment plants additionally we are
investigating the genetic factors that
affect drug metabolism helping us
optimize the drug
prescriptions next is infectious
diseases so here we are exploring the
genetic diversity and the evolution of
the influenza virus in different regions
and this knowledge can help us design uh
either better vaccines or antiviral
drugs a better therapeutic approach in
short and we would also like to study
the transmission dynamics of diseases
like U malaria aiming to reduce their
spread in endemic
regions so that was about these three
different tracks and what topics are we
focusing on the next one is neuroscience
so in Neuroscience we are focused on
understanding the underlying molecular
and cellular mechanisms of neuro
degenerative diseases like Alzheimer's
or Parkinson's and our goal is to
develop Innovative therapies to slow or
ha disease progressions and we are also
exploring how genetics and epigenetics
influence brain development and the risk
of mental health disorders like
schizophrenia aiming to identify early
biomarkers for early
intervention another field is
agriculture where we want to look at
ways to optimize crop breeding using
genomic data and also we are studying
the the genetic factors and metabolic
pathways that make the plant resistant
to pests or diseases and diseases with
the aim of promoting sustainable and
eco-friendly farming
practices next is metabolic re uh
disorders metabolic disorders research
centers on understanding the molecular
factors that contributes to condition
like insulin resistance in type two
diabetes so we are working on targeted
therapies to in improve insulin
sensitivity and additionally we also
want to investigate the metabolic
underpinnings of obesity and its related
Health complications such as fatty liver
disease and our goal is to develop
personalized interventions for weight
management last but not the least is
space
omx why space omic so in the fascinating
real of space omic we are researching
how Extended space missions affect the
human microbiome and this knowledge can
help us develop strategies to mitigate
health risks associated with microbiome
changes during space travel we are also
exploring the genomic and the proteomic
changes in organisms export to extreme
conditions in space and this information
can um this specific information would
inform the development of biot
technological solutions for space
exploration as well as
colonization these were some FS that I
wanted to discuss some topics that we
are working on and have plans to work on
and also uh there are other fields that
uh I have not discussed in Greater
detail but if you're interested let us
know you can email us we can uh have an
expiratory call with you and discuss and
those things would be around chem
informatics that we can uh discuss
specifically around chem
informatics so those were some of the
topics under the beginner level that uh
I wanted to discuss next comes the
intermediate level curriculum again to
mention the ones who take up
intermediate or advanced level would
definitely have the access to the
beginner level sessions that I discussed
but the one who takes up the
intermediate level has to propose his or
her own research proposal has to propose
his or her own research question so if
you already have a uh question in your
head but you want to discuss with us PR
it a little bit and then you have a
proposal ready you submit it to us and
um then we start working on it so you
perform the literature revie you look
for the data set you explore the data
set and you process all and you um go
ahead with all the pre-processing steps
and the analysis you'll have all our
support we'll be assisting you at every
step but it's just that the research
question is yours the intermediate level
is for three months you get more time to
work on your research resarch project
and because you will get more time to
work on your research project that's why
you have some more sessions to refer to
to get that learning to learn about
specific types of omix analysis now
these training sessions would basically
help you build your Concepts so these
training sessions are actually a series
of lectures and also some coursework
that you have to complete that will
assist you to complete your research
project as I mentioned the outcome of
the beginner level could be a research
project a mini project but the outcome
of an intermediate level could be a
desertation project so a lot of Bachelor
and master students uh have this
criteria to have a desertation project
submitted to their college or university
to get their final degree so the
intermediate level would cater to that
need where you can work on your
desertation project obviously because
you get more time so you can uh work on
this specific or you can work in this
specific
Direction now let's discuss what the
training of uh the intermediate level
would look like so as I mentioned that
you have to pick your own research
question that's why it's very important
for you to understand the different
resource specialization tracks today I
just introduced you to the tracks I did
not discuss much in depth about each one
of these so in the seventh session we
will discuss about each research
specialization track in detail and based
on your interest you can pick the one
that you want to work on we will explore
the unique challenges and the
opportunities within each specialization
that will allow you to align your
research uh to focus with your
passion and the eighth session would be
around omix databases and data retrieval
so let's say you have a resarch
specialization track that you want to
work on for example you want to work on
oncology next thing is to uh first of
all pick up a specific type of interest
of uh omx data that you want to work
with let's say uh amongst all those
different omic data types genomics
transcriptomics metag genomics and
single cell or epig genomics I say I
want to work with transcriptomic data so
the track is oncology I want to work
with transcriptomic data related to
oncology it could be any type of cancer
um let's say I pick liver cancer the
next thing would be to extract the data
to look for data I want to look for
liver cancer data sets so it's very
important for you to learn what are the
different omix databases from where you
can retrieve the data so in this session
we will introduce you to various omix
databases and the importance of data
retrieval now data retrieval is not very
easy different databases have uh data
uploaded uh in different formats and in
different ways so how do you retrieve
the data how do you uh clean the data
those are some of the things that we
will be
discussing so here you will learn how to
navigate and extract the relevant data
from the databases to support your
research now there are different uh omix
tracks that you that you could pick you
omics metag genomics or transcriptomics
now here you have a choice it's not that
you take all the sessions I said that
I'm interested in transcriptomics so if
my interest is transcriptomics I just
take 11th and 12th session if your
interest is metagenomic you just take
metagenomic session why we have put
these sessions here so that we can guide
you in more depth how to work with a
specific type of omx analysis if it is
genomic data analysis that is your
interest so we'll teach you or we'll
delve into the genomic data analysis
that will focus on variant calling to
identify genetic variations and you'll
also learn how to perform functional
annotation to understand the
implications of genetic changes and the
philogenetic analysis to trace
evolutionary relationships so we'll
discuss these different uh possible
analysis that comes under genomic data
analysis or that is possible with
genomic data okay next is met genomic
data analysis now metagenomic data
analysis is essential for understanding
the complex microbial communities as I
mentioned and because you now want to
analyze or understand the composition or
the abundance of these different
microbial communities it's important for
you to learn about different tools and
techniques that you could use uh to
analyze microbial data now these tools
could be like data to or kind those are
the two specific pipelines that we would
be focusing on that will help you
understand how to process and analyze
data allowing you to explore microbial
diversity taxonomic classification Alpha
Beta diversity um etc etc the list goes
on and in the next sessions session 11
and 12 you will learn about
transcriptomic data analysis so R is a
powerful tool for gene expression an
analysis and many of you might have a
good Hands-On with this type of analysis
as well but if not then these sessions
will help you learn how to ex um how to
explore the data so once you have the
data with you you need to perform
exploratory analysis to understand the
data set in your hand we'll discuss
various statistical methods for
differential gene expression analysis in
this session the next session is uh on
differential gene expression analysis
where we'll dive deeper into the
analysis of differential gene expression
that's a very critical component of omx
research you'll learn how to identify
the genes that are significantly
upregulated or down regulated in
different conditions which is crucial
for understanding biological
processes so the intermediate
level sessions will build on the
foundation that you establish in the
beginner level that allows you to
specialize in a specific research track
and also gain in-depth knowledge in omix
data analysis that is valuable for your
research
Fellowship so that was all about the
intermediate
level the next level is the advanced
level so for those who are aiming to
publish their work the advanced level is
where it all comes together so in the
intermediate level you could just St to
the need of submitting a desertation to
your
um college or university or maybe work
on a research project if you're a PhD
scholar but if you have a requirement to
publish a paper it's very obvious that
it's not possible in a span of three
months to learn work on a project and
then also publish your work uh that's
why the advanced level was uh developed
or put together that will help you
advanced level is for six months first
of all and this specific level will help
you with the specific set of tools and
techniques that you require to perform
uh a good research work and also have
the opportunity and the time definitely
to uh prepare a manuscript that could be
further
published now while I mentioned the
advanced level will give you the access
to these sessions uh that would help you
in advanced research and I say so we
learn we learned about different omix
analysis in the intermediate level it's
very important for you to also learn
about the tools and the techniques that
could be used uh to perform analysis
with that specific type of data or
perform Advanced analysis I'll say uh in
the intermediate level you learned about
genomics metag genomics transcriptomic
you need to pick one track of your
interest advanced level will help you
learn about uh single cell data analysis
or single cell transcript Armic data
analysis the first three sessions of the
advanced level are around omix analysis
and then are the tools and the
techniques the 13th session is about
pathway and functional enrichment
analysis where we delve into advanced RN
analysis where you want to learn about
the pathways or the function enrichment
of the differentially expressed change
you want to understand which which
Pathways your differentially expressed
genes effect and um also you want to
understand the INR along with the enr
pathways the functions of uh the
function of your dgs providing valuable
insights into the underlying
biology the next two sessions are on
single cell data analysis it is one of
those techniques uh or analysis that a
lot of researchers are working on but
because the sequencing of this type of
uh data is qu uh is uh quite costly
that's why it's not a routine or you'll
not find a lot of single cell data
available but there are a lot of
databases from where you can extract
single cell data and you also have uh an
amazing Pipeline on single cell data
analysis so uh for this for this
specific track we have put two sessions
so here we will explore the databases
first of all how to retrieve the data
what are the different types of
techniques to get the access or retrieve
the data and work with the specialized
data and we'll understand where and how
to optain the single cell data that is
crucial for advanced research and
building on the previous session we'll
then dive into the analysis of single
cell data focusing on cell type
identification differential expression
trajectory analysis some Advanced out of
analysis and also learn about or
understand about cellular heterogenity
and Dynamics so that was about
the omix analysis different types of
omix analysis now if you're not
interested in single cell but if you
want want to do genomic data analysis
you just refer to the genomic session
and not the Single Cell one that's an
option given to you but we definitely
will recommend that you take up these
sessions so that you learn about the
different types of omic analysis and
maybe in future you can uh work with any
other type of
analysis and then from the 16th session
onwards we are talking about the um most
talked about topics data science so data
science we'll here introduce you to the
data science principles and the
techniques that are specific to omix
data you'll explore data pre-processing
feature engineering model selection and
for more Advanced Data analysis you can
refer to it we'll also uh teach you
about machine learning different types
of machine learning unsupervised
analysis supervised analysis what are
these different different tools that
could be used for both of these
different types of analysis and how do
you work with them we'll teach you
through the automated pipelines and also
through
script so that was about unsupervised
and supervised analysis of machine
learning and we have three sessions on
supervised analysis taking each
algorithm at a time and then following
the process where you have the data and
then you prepare your data and then you
separate it into training and test set
and then you apply different algorithms
check the accuracy evaluate your model
and then you deploy it I've just given
you a very brief overview so we'll
discuss the entire flow and also we'll
discuss about each and every tool why is
it used how is it useful when to use it
U etc
etc okay now in the next sessions we
will discuss about um R in Python not
everyone is um a a techy here not
everyone wants to get into the coding
but those who are interested to learn R
and python for biomedical data analysis
I think the advanced level is best for
them because uh learning R and python
will um I say make you a full package of
where you know about the different types
of analysis and also you know about
different libraries that could be used
for this analysis so it will um help you
build a good research project but also
gain a good experience uh along
so in the next session we introduce you
to the languages first of all it's not
important that you have to learn R and
python both alongside you can pick one
language at a time either r or python
we'll give you the resources to learn
any of the languages r or python for
biomedical analysis if you want to learn
both of them perfect so here we'll
discuss about R and python we introduce
you to the languages how to process data
how to perform expiratory anal is how to
perform statistical analysis also in the
session name we have not mentioned but
in the coursework you'll learn about
machine learning as well how to apply or
build different machine learning models
using R and python now we get one
question a lot of times how many hours
you need to dedicate for each level see
the number of hours is is it's really it
really depends on you now there are some
people if you have a nonbi informatics
background you might have to give more
number of USS if you are a working
professional and you have time on
weekends you can give more time on
weekends and you can accommodate your
timings on the week days and if you are
a student and you have more time uh on
the week week days as well then you can
accommodate accordingly there are some
students who are fast Learners so you
might require less time so accordingly
we provide you with the resources it
completely depends on you how much time
you take to go through these resources
but yes we'll do provide you with
deadlines to make sure that you achieve
your mark on time and uh we we'll keep
assisting you with your questions
clarify your doubts and uh take you a
step ahead towards your
research so that was about the different
levels beginner intermediate and Advance
if you have any questions you can put in
the uh chat box
and I'll now take you to the uh omic
learn portal where I'll just show you
all these different levels and what
resources what access to the resources
you have any
questions you can also unmute
yourself
all right so if there are no questions I
now proceed ahead so uh this is the
program page that you might have seen on
the social media as well so once you're
on the omx logic learn portal you will
find this page under the program St this
program page is very important for the
program because you'll find all the
associated
resources uh that I just went through
the sessions the recordings the lectures
the course work everything on the
program page how can we get the data if
you're interested in particular topic
that's what we'll teach you how to get
or extract the data from databases or
repositories for a specific topic that
you're
interested uh Dohan is asking how how we
will do our analysis as we know that
bioinformatics need large computer
resource which maybe our machine can't
run though the answer is T bioinfo
platform I just take you to the T
bioinfo platform where you have these
pipelines you just need to extract the
data uh through links you can refer to
the specific data set that you want to
work with upload your data here or uh
put the links to that specific data set
from the from the data repository and
everything will run on server you'll be
given 5tb space where everything uh
would be done from pipeline processing
you get the results you just have to
download the result and interpret them
okay uh I'll take you through the
platform just give me uh five minutes
five more minutes I'll just take you to
the platform it's not an online machine
it's an it's a server basically it's an
online server and your are allocated
space on the server and you can uh run
the educational pipelines to learn first
of all how the analysis is performed and
then you perform it with your own data
so that is how it would
work okay now um I'll tell you how to
get to the program page I'll just show
you the different components of the
program page and then I'll take you to
the resources that you get an access to
with the program when I say resources I
am referring to the coursework and this
platform T bi info platform to um
process the pipelines so there are two
things don't get confused onx logic
learn portal that is like your uh
training guide you have all the
resources here to learn from then you
have the TB for platform to perform the
Practical
Hands-On so you go to the programs and
here on the second page you can also put
in the search bar research and you'll
get this program
page now on this program page if you
scroll down you have the specifications
of the program then you have these three
different levels beginner intermediate
or Advance you have to pick up one of
the levels based on your research
interest and I'll just take you shortly
how do you register on the program page
itself you'll find these different
levels you pick the specific level that
you want to enroll with and then you the
moment you do so you'll unlock that
specific level for yourself so here you
have these different sessions these are
the sessions that I took you through uh
when I was going through the
presentation and here you'll find the
link to the lecture you'll find the link
to the resources which will include
coursework uh the courses that you have
to go through supplementary material
additional material link to literature
or research articles or additional
material that you can go through all
right and you just have to watch it
complete the material and work on a
research project we will be meeting
every week where we will discuss your
progress we'll take up your queries
we'll um take up your queries and
rectify them and help you proceed ahead
with the next step now what are the
resources that come along I mentioned
course work so you would pick one type
of omix analysis let's say uh you want
to work with transcript omic data you
pick one type of omix analysis learn how
that specific type of omix analysis is
performed and and then when you have to
select a research question or an area
that you want to work on uh then you
pick up a resarch specialization track
if you want to analyze RNC data for an
Alzheimer's condition or for a specific
type of cancer or for um metabolic
disorders diabetes or obesity that way
so now let's say you want to learn about
transcriptomics uh before I hit on the
transcriptomics course work let's jump
to the initial step let's say you are a
newb and you don't have an idea what
specific type of omix do you want to
refer to for uh you as a newb we'll take
you through the first course that is
Introduction to
bioinformatics now this specific course
will introduce you to the different
fields of omix genomics transcriptomics
metag genomics it will help you
understand understand what this field is
all about what this field includes what
type of data has to be analyzed in this
field and different applications so this
this is a coursework these are different
lessons you open up a lesson inside the
lesson you have context you have images
uh to supplement your understanding you
have videos to watch you have quizzes
and assignments to answer to check your
knowledge so that is uh how a lesson is
built okay
now you go through the this cours work
and then you let us know which specific
failure interested to work with now the
next step is let's say you specify that
transcriptomics is that area that you
want to work with sorry for
the typo okay you mentioned that you
want to work with transcriptomics so the
next step would be an advanced training
you go through the transomics course
workor now in this course work we start
from the very Basics uh even if you
don't have a background with
transcriptomics it's perfectly fine we
start with the very Basics we'll start
with the concepts of uh what is
transcriptomics how transcriptomic data
is sequenced what are the different
sequencing techniques what are the
different sequencing types and then once
you have this data how do you clean the
data what are the steps involved to
clean the data pre-process the data uh
and then perform expirat or Downstream
analysis what is the flow and also what
are the different tools that are that
you have to use okay so inside these
lessons you have the concepts explained
and you also have the Practical Hands-On
explained so you have the steps that you
need to perform so uh if I I'm not wrong
Dohan yes Dohan asked how to perform the
practical hands on okay uh we definitely
know that a system will support it not
everyone has a high Computing system
actually no one has it with them at
their
places sorry so uh in the cour workk you
have these
lessons where you have the steps
specified you you have a detailed
description on what the what tools are
to be used what those tools do and uh
what are the different steps what are
the different parameters and then how to
com um complete the processing of the
pipeline and then what results you get
and how to interpret them so that is one
thing now everything from the very
beginning understanding how the data is
preprocessed to expiratory analysis or
uh Downstream
analysis the next thing is you learn how
to perform statistical analysis or tests
differential expression analysis
regression analysis machine learning
everything around transer toic data
right once you have completed the uh
coursework and once you have a good
Hands-On the specific type of data
analysis the next step is just to get an
overview of how the concepts that you
learned could be applied to answer a
research question before you really
start working with your research
question so you went through the
coursework first of all you identified
your area after that you picked up a
specific coursework learn the analysis
and this coursework would also be
supplemented with Mentor lectures you
watch the lectures for each step
understand the flow and then you also go
through some case studies these case
studies are not very lengthy they're
very short case studies but it will help
you build a concept so after you know
the concept how to use it to apply uh to
a research question that is what you
will learn okay so that was about about
the coursework that you uh have to
complete uh as a part of the program
that's actually not not a lot of cours
workor uh it's basically it's definitely
a gradual learning process you learn a
thing and then you apply it so that's
the way it should work I mentioned about
the T bio info server so let's have a
look at it th this is the Practical
handson platform that you would have to
uh use now definit
there are three things that we would
refer to we'll refer to open databases
to extract data we also refer uh we'll
also refer to the uh open uh or publicly
available tools and techniques that you
can use or publicly available softwares
that you can use for analysis and we'll
also explore the T bioinfo platform so
we'll explore all the different aspects
of bioinformatics tools softwares and
techniques uh in R and python as well
that you can use to analyze your data
so when it comes to the T bioinfo
platform there are different areas of
analysis on the platform transcriptomics
genomics single cell metagenomics uh
virology uh then you have the ftic
analysis here for machine learning you
have pipelines there are several
pipelines uh I'll just take few minutes
of yours I know we are uh at the time of
ending the webinar but I just take a few
minutes to give you a quick Hands-On
with what these lines are and show you
how to process them and how to interpret
the data so here you have these
dropdowns these dropdowns have some case
studies or pre-built pipelines we call
them demo pipelines why they are called
demo pipelines here the data is already
uploaded at the back end and you just
need to process the pipeline look at the
result and understand what these results
are and learn to interpret the result
it's not difficult on a platform to uh
uh take the data and process the
pipeline but it's important for you to
understand how to interpret the result
so how do you upload your data the this
is a usual pipeline you simply upload
your file it could be your txt file it
has to be your txt file or an svl link
or HTTP link or FTP link so Dohan you
were asking uh how do we do that we can
also refer to these different links that
we can get from the databases okay and
then we upload our data and then we
process the pipeline I'll Qui quickly
take you through one of these pipeline
processing so this is a pipeline I can
simply start the pipeline use some
specific uh
algorithms uh what these algorithms are
why am I using them what parameters do I
need to put everything we'll teach you
in the program right now I just wanted
to show you how easy it is to uh process
a pipeline and then you have your
results that you can
interpret you get the results here you
can click on then it'll download these
are zi findes you unzip them and then
you explore them and you get a dashboard
where you can um change the parameters
and see how your results change with
change in parameters and then these are
the interactive plots that you get
through the pipeline that you can
interact with and interpret your
results so that was a very quick and a
brief demonstration of the T bioinfo
platform there are various pipelines
that we could use for different types of
analysis we'll be talking more about
them once you join the program and with
that I'll pass on the stage to Shri Cori
to quickly show us the outcomes of the
program and uh then we'll discuss the
registration process and then we'll be
good to end the session if there are any
questions please feel free to put in the
chat
thank you so
mucha I'll just quickly share my
screen so uh the participants have any
queries please feel free to put it in
the chat and along the way we'll be able
to uh answer your question so uh
sunalika gave a very comprehensive
introduction to the various
specialization fact that are there as a
part of the uh research fellowship
program and now we'll take a look at
some of the ways that uh the students
have leveraged these training program
and the resources who come up with
various uh outut so in this case as you
can see uh the research program was
integrated as a part of the University
curriculum which was part of the systems
medicine graduate program at Georgetown
University and the training program
ended with students completing a diverse
range of research projects on machine
learning using python to address various
research questions in biomedical
research such as infectious diseases
metabolic disorders Neuroscience
oncology and so further students have
also went on to participate in post
presentation competitions that we
conduct annually which is the omix resar
Symposium wherein International experts
will attend review your research project
and provide feedback on how you can
improve it further and there are also
students who have went on to publish
their research project in Open Access
journals uh such as W who is a
biomedical sence uh student who is
interested in Immunology research
specialization and let's say if you're
someone who is interested in cancer
diagnosis treatment then you can also
offer the oncology specialization like
or did who went on to publish her
research project that's part of
University at columia and there are also
uh students coming from the high school
background for example mosa who
presented his Neuroscience project at
the regenon international science and
engineering fair for which he won the
BAM and presently he is olled in an
undergraduate program at Harvard
University and we also have H students
who complete their uh research project
to participate in International
Conference
like Priyanka Sharma and P they were
from biotechnology background and these
projects can also be showcased as a part
of your University application like some
of our students did such as jaraa Anisha
they all went on to Showcase their
research project in
their resume as part of their University
applications now taking the example of
Dela itself if you're someone who is
interested in astrobiology and face
comic we had a lot of students from that
background who are still uh actively uh
passionate about the theme and you can
find a lot of their uh session
discussions as part of the student club
that we have on the YouTube channel now
moving on if you're someone who is
interested in infectious
diseases uh that is also posable and
here is an interesting example where in
the faculties and researchers uh
collaborated through our research
program to publish their research book
and this particular example is part of
the Nei Memorial Institute for medical
research part of university of Ghana and
let's say you're someone with a passion
for Science and business then it is also
possible to pursue an entrepreneurship
and business Innovation track like a
team of industrial researchers from
biologic Support Services which is a
biotechnology company in Nigeria de so
they specialized in the uh microbiome
metagenomics and they developed a
microbiome test kit to improve the
fertility of women in Nigeria and the
interesting aspect is that such
entrepreneurship tracks are not just
pursued by researchers but by students
as well here is an example of a group of
undergraduate and postgraduate students
from India who develop an early
detection kit for
Al and now to regularly stay updated
about our ongoing research project
opportunities student applications
exciting job opportunities latest re
research articles and there um in btics
and data science we encourage you to
follow our LinkedIn group on machine
learning and data science where you will
get frequent updates uh as well as
student days so that is all that I
wanted to discuss about the outcomes
that are there as part of the research
program and I'll share the link to these
groups in the chat box so that the
participants can can uh join the group
get started so uh now I'd like to pass
on the state back
to we'll walk you through the
registration process and how one can so
over to
you thank you Shari okay so now how do
you register for the program so to
register for the program you need to go
to the program page go to the programs
Tab and there was a question is it easy
to access the omic portal yes it is very
easy but if you have any sorts of um
technical problems navigating the
program you can anytime reach out to us
and we can have a call with you
oneon-one where we can tell you how to
uh navigate the program the portal all
right so once you're on the program page
you scroll down and you have these three
sections bner intermediate and the
advanced level and uh based on whichever
level that you are interested to enroll
in you can pick the pick that level
based on the country that you are
present let's say I'm from India so if I
uh select INR I'll get these three
different levels we are offering
scholarships at the moment and uh we had
a lot of queries in the chat box as well
for the scholarships yes we are offering
scholarships you can reach out to us on
Communications at the rate find. bio and
uh just put
your uh educational background or if you
are working somewhere you put your
research position name of the
institution or the university and then
you put the scholarship uh reason right
so there's a form that you have to fill
for the scholarship so you email shrii
she can put her email address in the
chat and you just fill out that form
we'll review your application and then
we'll review and then we'll give you a
discount code you take that discount
code click on the buy now button for
whichever level that you want to enroll
in and then you put that specific coupon
code over here and then you click on the
apply button and once you do that the
amount would be uh deduced so that is
how you uh get the scholarship and use
that cin code to put him right so if
you're seeking for a scholarship please
feel free to reach out to us Shari
please put your email address in the
chat box so that uh we can help you get
a scholarship and start with the program
these scholarships are available for um
students from lwi income countries and
also from students from from specific
institutions and universities that's why
I asked you to mention your institution
or university as well now just to
discuss about the uh spe specificities
for each of these different levels that
I discussed I'll repeat once again for
the beginner
level you get an access for two months
intermediate gives you an access for
three months Advanced gives you an
access for six months in the beginner
level you will be working on a
predefined research question we'll give
you some research questions you either
you can pick from it or the research uh
projects that are ongoing in the company
you you can become a part of that
project and have a customized research
question that you can work on
specifically for your research project
report okay the outcome of the pner
level would be a research project report
that you can submit to your college or
have an experience with and also high
schoolers can enroll in the beginner
level they can take the other levels as
well but if you wish to work on a mini
project for an exhibition or a fair then
you can pick the beginner level and then
comes the intermediate level
that is for three months here you have
to propose your own research question
we'll assist you work on the research
question if you don't have a research
question and uh then you can also uh
work on the specific research question
for three months and the outcome of the
intermediate level would be a
desertation maybe that you can submit it
could also be a poster we can help you
with creating the poster for of your
specific research book that you can
present maybe in conferences
um or we can also assist you for these
posters in uh poster competitions in
your campus University or college and
then the advanced level is specifically
for those who want to get an advanced
Hands-On with the tools and techniques
of data science that would be used to
apply to their research question and
they want to have research publication
out of their um research work so they
can pick the advanced level that is for
six months so BAS based on your
requirements you can pick the level that
you want again for scholarships you
should email Shri gari on Communications
atate pine. bio and we'll revie your
application and give you a couping
code all right are there any
questions just a clarification here that
so most of the participants I believe
have already subed their applications
through the form so we'll review that U
existing um submissions that you have
and for those who are new and joining us
for the first time and have not
submitted please U register through the
form I'll share it once again in the
chat box and for after reviewing the
submissions and the selected candidates
will be emailed with the scholarship uh
code that will be
providing just
that
if if anyone has any further queries um
let us
know and feel free to connect with us on
LinkedIn uh we have the groups by omix
Logic uh we keep on updating there about
the scholarships available about the
ongoing research work so if you go on
LinkedIn you have the pages here omx
logic one is this page and then you also
have and then we also have a group that
you can join just WR onx logic and feel
free to connect with us on
LinkedIn uh Shar you were mentioning
something please over to
you uh yes we have one query from
miracle that he is a graduate of
biochemistry and he is not currently
enrolled in any institution but he needs
the research experience for application
Pro so can I qualify to the scholarship
regarding yes yes definitely uh you'll
qualify for the scholarship uh please
mention or please share your resume with
us you can uh we just want to look your
educational background look at your
educational background and also look at
the previous research projects that you
have worked on that would help
us I shared the email ID in the chat box
so if you have any query you can drop an
email there and our team will get
back perfect thank you so much sh uh do
we have any other questions what percent
of discount there are different uh
scholarships that we are offering based
on the background the student background
so once you send your application to us
we let you know what scholarship do you
get
you can uh share it directly uh with
Shri Gori on communication aomix
logic.com
yes all right thank you everyone for
joining today's session and uh we'll see
you in the program once you join the
program we'll have an orientation
session to get you started and we'll
keep on meeting every week to look at
your progress and help you with the next
steps see you all in the program
bye-bye